take me
through that day if you could 1972 when
you were going for the 68 kilogram
freestyle wrestling gold you scored
57 points if i'm correct and has zero
points scored on you
57 0. so maybe
uh take me through almost the details
what was your routine what was your
process what was going through your mind
your thoughts of that day
yeah first of all uh it was it was quite
a day
because uh we weighed in every day
at that time and that and that yeah we
weighed in two hours before the start of
the competition
and so that didn't mean that you weighed
in two hours for your russell because
you didn't know whether you're gonna
wrestle right away or later on
in fact in that day i don't think i
wrestled uh until
later on in the evening so had all day
to recover but
i didn't really need it anyway because
you know i wasn't really
pulling a whole lot of weight but just
uh it was just interesting
but what was in your mind what would
what were you thinking were you nervous
were you
i was confident i was confident you knew
you were going to win the gold
yeah i knew i was going to win uh but in
reality
you're i'm not i didn't know it from a
cocky point of view
i only knew it because for the last
three and a half years i've been going
to practice
and i'd be winning every practice you
felt good and i
hardly ever lose a takedown and if i
lost this if i
somebody scored on me it was like
when i went to bed i couldn't sleep
until i figured it out
or if i didn't figure it out i would
fall asleep
and i would be whoa i would wake up with
the answer of what i needed why i got
scored upon
so maybe now that you've won the gold
can you tell me in the practice room
when somebody took you down
how how do you take dan gable down in
the in the practice room
timing very difficult but yes somebody
could
because they were going for one move
all i wanted was one move whereas you
know if you can arrest somebody and rush
the whole practice or half of practice
for at least 10 15 minutes
and they were maybe gonna score
if they could work it in their mind
but they knew that was going to be their
victory so in the practice room
maybe you can educate me at that when
you're going for the olympic gold
er you didn't want to allow any
takedowns so there's no such thing as
working on some kind of
weird position a weak point to something
it's important to not let down
take down it's kind of like what we're
saying before
if something happened and somebody
scored on me in a certain way
i would go over that situation over that
situation over it again
and i would come up with an answer and
then i would actually test it
maybe i wouldn't go right back the next
day because i didn't want the guy to
you know do not have some i didn't want
him to think that i was
thinking about it all night i didn't
tell him but maybe three days later when
he wrestled again
i actually had it figured out because
it it he wasn't able to or if even if i
was in on to take
a a an offensive move and i got stopped
and didn't score
you know i had to go back and filter
that
but it wasn't something that usually i
couldn't solve
right i could usually solve it
you